So hello. Hello. This is not going to be a cold open. This is going to be a hot open. This is hot. Yeah. Let's make it hot. Let's give it a little bit of a summer theme on this hot open.
Oh, a summer. So here we are. So we're on the beach and oh, look at those waves. Beautiful. Is that a surfer out there? It looks like Will Arnett. Will, get on in here. We're doing a hot open.
Paddling in, he's paddling in. Hey, you guys cool with the G string? Yeah. Ah, it has no front. No, Will, don't turn around, don't turn around. Welcome to Smartless. Smartless. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Um, Jay, did you sleep okay? I slept like a log.
Yeah. Willie, you were missed last night. Lemon Bundt cake and Rice Krispies really put me down. We went back to the Bundt cake, huh? Whose was that? Was that yours, Seanny? No, that was a gift that somebody else brought in. Yeah, you were missed, Will.
I missed it, yeah. I'm sorry I didn't come. I had a dinner with the boys. By boys, I mean my sons. Not with my golf buddies or something. Yeah, we had a nice, just my boys and me, which was really nice. That's nice, isn't it nice? Did you watch a movie?
No, we watched a little Sunday night football, which was fun. All the snow. And then we did, sorry, so then we did do, we do movie night at night before bed. The littles like to watch a little movie. They call it movie night. Usually ends up being, put a movie on in my room
on the bed and then it turns into fight. Everybody gets weapons. Oh yeah. You don't fall asleep right away? So last night, Daddy hadn't seen Star Wars and he kept saying, this is the real movie. We're like, I know, from moment one, he's like, what's he doing?
What's this guy doing? Are there any dead? He literally at one point goes, this is a great human, totally human pure moment. He goes, as C3P and R2D2 are walking on Tatooine, Sean, hold your boner. He goes, that's a desert? And we go, yeah. And he goes, there's no sea there.
You go, no, he goes, I'm thirsty. It was so funny just right in that moment to say that. So anyway. Wait, but back to football. Yesterday I was watching football too and I don't understand why they, the guy, when they know they have a camera on them, they just hold one nostril and they blow it out
the other way. And it's so, they're always on camera just blowing their nose out. It's like, just get a Kleenex. Oh, you're right, they should go get Kleenexes on the side of the... Yeah, they hand them everything else. Excuse me, stop the play.
Excuse me, can I get a Kleenex? But why do they all spit in baseball too? I get that the chewing tobacco and stuff, but you know, only half the guys are chewing tobacco now. It's just, but it's like this weird like, I'm a male, check it out. I can spit. People on the street too that just like spit when they're like kind of uncomfortable
or they know eyes are on them. It's like, yeah, I'm a dude. People on the fucking golf course do it. Guys, it's like you're not a real man, guy. We're just out here playing golf. I know. I was in Germany with Scotty on a vacation and I spit in public.
He didn't talk to me the rest of the day. Yeah, like what's the matter with you? Yeah, we're on a huge fight. I just spit on the- Now you've got an escape valve, you know what I mean? If you think about it. But like why would, you know, you can swallow saliva. Like it's built for that.
Yeah, but if you have to get it out, what do you do? But exactly, but what saliva is so bad that you've got to get it out, put it on the ground? Here's an interesting thing. I was chewing tobacco, I get it. Here's the irony, is that knowing JB as well as I do, and you and I know him almost as well as anybody, he could go either way with that.
He could see somebody, work up like have some spit and swallow it and go, gross, why don't you just get rid of it? Why would you, am I right about that, James? Yes, I could argue both sides. That is so true. I know, it's so true, right? Do you think if I was a lawyer,
would I have been a defense attorney or a prosecutor? Both, you would have been both. Yeah. You would have come in, your honor, I'm representing both of you. Because I don't want anyone's involvement? No, and you don't want to be caught out being wrong in either way.
So you're just like, I'm going to cover both. My dad does that. My dad goes, he'll say, he'll make a point, he'll go blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, and you're about, you go intake, you're about to make a point, and he'll go, having said that, and you're like, oh, you're going to argue the other side?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. We're going to make a point, and he'll go, having said that, and you're like, oh, you're going to argue the other side of the road? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. We're going to get to our guest right now, but Jason told, I've never heard that story unless you told it and I don't remember, and we don't have to tell it right now, but Jason was doing a play and he bought the cast. Oh my God, that story.
I was trying to remember what story I told you last night. God, it was so funny. I think I've said that on this before. Really? I don't remember. Just some horrible example of what a fucking monster I was in my early 20s. Did we talk about last time the thing
that we're not gonna talk about yet? We did, right? What's that? Yes, no, yeah, please don't even think about it. We did, right? What is that? I don't know, I'm just going home. The stuff that we're looking into doing with, did we?
Oh, I don't know. You guys are in control of all in control. We didn't actually talk about it. Did we know words that that word we decided doing something We're really excited. We don't want to say yet, but we are excited About something because we've had we've had the three of us have talked to People have said to us like hey, you should do something with the brand as gross as that sounds. Very gross. And then, right for a while, we've sort of, and kind of like when we were thinking about going on tour,
we were like, hey, should we do that blah, blah, blah. So then we were like, should we do something? And then we've sort of zeroed in on something that we are gonna do within the smart list world that we're really excited about. We can't really say, yet, I'm sorry, we're not sort of teasing it on purpose to not make you guess, but it is something that we are excited about
and when it finally comes to fruition. So kind of bear with us, but it's something pretty cool and that feels really organic to what we do. Right. Right. But first we're going to say hello. Yes. Ah, how about that? Yep. We're huge fans of our guest today,
not just his prolific work, but the man behind the empire is a dear friend to all of us. A self-proclaimed weird kid, his favorite holiday was Halloween. After graduating from Vassar, his career started as a real estate agent in Manhattan before working his way up at a major movie studio. Today he's a three-time Academy Award nominated,
two-time Prime Time Academy Award winning, and a three-time Peabody Award winning producer. His company for which he is CEO and founder is considered the driving force in one of the last genres to get people into the theaters. He's our brilliant friend Jason Blum. Jason Blum of Blumhouse. Oh look at him.
Oh, Blumhouse, hello there. Oh he's got his little warm jacket on. Look at him go. We're doing it, we're finally doing it. This is a very, very important day for me. This is, everybody just take it easy right now. Well, it's not probably the listeners who are as excited as I am.
Because what I'd like to share with all your fans, by the way, I have, I guess like all your guests have been listening, the way not to sell your product is literally the last five minutes is exactly, you basically said we're doing something, someday we're going to tell you about it. I've never, I mean that was. We're stupid.
It was, it was unbelievable, which is why, which is why I'm, which is why I'm very happy to be here to kind of help you with your chocolate bars, you know. Your chocolate bars. Well, it's just like, well, if you were like selling one of your movies, it's like buying a billboard and just having it just be black. We might make a scary movie, it might come out someday,
and I'm not telling you what it's called. Yeah. Listen. What, so. By the way, effective. Yeah, but for my sister sister who may not know you, but knows the name of your company, Blumhouse, Blumhouse makes all the hit horror films you've ever seen
and it's all because of you. Every horror film out there is basically, every hit horror film is basically a Blumhouse. You're saying horror, right? Horror, yeah. Horror. Horror. Horror. Scary. Okay.
Yeah, I just gotta get something off my mind first though before we start talking about horror. Horror, right? Horror, yeah. Horror. Horror. Horror. Scary. Yeah, I just got to get something off my mind first though before I start talking about horror. I just, because you guys are being really polite, which I appreciate, but I think it's important for all your gazillions of listeners to know that I know all of you individually. Yes.
I've known Jason the longest, but you know, we have relationships and I think it's important for everyone to know that individually, over the last, since, how long has Smartness been? Two or three years? Five years? Four and a half. Four and a half years.
I've probably over the last four years sent a total of 15 emails, five to each of you, every three or four months, timed separately, begging to be on the show. Timed separately. Begging. Now the harshest response is Jason just doesn't reply. Love to promote the new movie on SmartList, ghosting me.
No. Not only that. I don't think so. I changed my email address. Which one? Not only emails and texts, you also have done individual lunches, dinners, and collective dinners.
And a collective dinner, yes, yes, yes. Lunches, collective dinners, and everyone in my family and everyone in my company knows this has been the golden chalice. So for me, I just need a moment to let this wash over me. Like this is a pinnacle. Forget those dumb awards. This is a mountain.
I've been trying to climb for four and a half years. The Ted Sarandos, if you remember, when he went on, I said, you gotta put, they're gonna put me on now. It's been two years since Ted's been on the show. I love that Blum said forget the dumb awards. He didn't say forget the money, because you never forget the money. But here's the one thing. Don't forget the money. Blum, let me say this Blum said forget the of the dumb awards He didn't say forget the money cuz you never forget
Let me say this let me say forget the money truth never forget the money No, no, no one is this you've you've known Jason the longest, but we met longer ago than any of us Oh, no, that's true in the mid 90s We had a dinner in which you spent 90% of it on the phone outside in the East Village with your former boss. Yes, being berated. Being berated. The other thing is, I noticed, you're wearing your jacket and one of the reasons is because
you've been sleeping outside. Yes, wait, yeah. Let's talk about that. Still not in profit. It's my favorite. I am still, since the moment you showed me your sleeping situation, Blum, I am obsessed with it. And people use obsessed, but I am still, since the moment you showed me your sleeping situation, Blum, I am obsessed with it. And people use obsessed, but I'm literally obsessed.
Walk us through it. I am too. Yeah. Walk us through it, please, if you can. My grandmother lived in Northern California in Petaluma where we still, I still have this little house and it was, I don't know if it was before air conditioning, but she didn't have air conditioning,
and they had these things, I guess in the 30s and 40s, really is when it started, called sleeping decks. And you would just kind of put a mattress and sleep outside in the summer to stay cool. And when I went to go visit my grandmother, I used to always sleep outside on a little mattress in a sleeping bag on the sleeping deck. And ever since that time, I've always wanted a house
where I could sleep outside. And about five years ago, we got this house in Rustic Canyon and I built a deck outside the bedroom. And we have a completely screened-in porch. There's no heat. And my wife and I sleep there every night. And it feels great. And now people don't realize, California,
it actually really does get really, really cold. Well, it gets cool at night. Yeah. 48, 46 is about the coldest that it gets. I sleep with a hat. See my hat? I sleep with the hat on. And I sleep with, I have, you know, sweats and sweatpants
and I don't wear gloves. And, and, and, and, and you don't need a sound machine because right next to the sleeping deck is a? A creek. There's a little creek. Yes, you just use... So we hear a little creek. You just use that. You have water and it's right in the middle of Santa Monica.
I mean, it's amazing. And I said to Blum, I go... And we were in there and he was showing me and I was just blown away and I go, especially as a Canadian, I was really impressed. And I said, I said, how do you sleep out here? And he goes, incredibly. Yeah. I know it's like that.
Incredibly. Yeah. But then he doubles down like. Incredibly, yeah. I mean, it's a. But then he doubles down, because what happens as soon as you wake up from that freezing night? Then I walk down, it's a balcony with an outdoor stairway and I do a jump in my cold plunge very quickly,
which is very trendy and pathetic, but I do it. And then I take a, then I. It's at what, 37 degrees? It's at 37, but I used to stay in for a minute every morning, and Vivi Nivo stays in for a minute or something, and I used to stay in for a minute every morning, and then I started getting sick. Like every two weeks I was getting a different sickness,
and I'm convinced it was because I was doing that. So now I just go in for like five seconds, wakes me up, and then I jump into a warm shower, and I'm on my way to school. Now, couldn't all of this be solved by just opening the windows in your main bedroom? Yeah, just open the windows. Not the same at all.
Not the same. Oh, not at all. Not the same. Not at all, not at all. Because every so often, we sleep in the bedroom with all the windows open, it's just, it's not the same. And Lauren's on board with all this. Does she do the cold plunge too?
She does not do the cold plunge, but she loves sleeping outside, and we sleep outside together every too? She does not do the cold plunge, but she loves sleeping outside and we sleep outside together every night. She doesn't do the cold plunge, but... Sean, you used to sleep outside, right? Sorry, a Five Guys. Every time they open a new Five Guys, you'd sleep outside.
Wait until it's open. Yeah, I got so excited. I'd starve myself. Now Jason, the eccentricities don't stop there. Let's talk to, let's explain to Tracy about the traffic situation and the parking situation in Los Angeles and how you've managed to circumvent that problem. Right, but before that, and yes, I want to hear that,
I just want to tell Tracy, like, you know, insidious, paranormal activity, the purge, get out, it goes on and on and on, I just want to let, get people off the seat. These are films that Jason has produced, is what you're trying to say. That's right, that's right. Yeah, he's responsible for all of these.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Split, Halloween, you left on a couple big Five Nights at Freddy's, Megan. That's right, that's right. Yeah, that's the actor. He's responsible for all of these. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Split, Halloween, you left out a couple big Five Nights at Freddy's, Megan. That's right. You left out a couple of big ones. The gift, which Jason was in, right? Most importantly, the gift. But I say all that because you can accomplish all this
because, to Jason's question, you have? A van. A van. Is that what you're talking about? That you drive around in. A van, a van. I'm obsessed with efficiency. I'm obsessed with efficiency. I'm obsessed with it.
Yes. And one of the things I was very fixated on is I've always kind of struggled with life in LA. And whether, you know, I always, I was very hot and cold in LA. But one of the things I really don't like is driving and traffic and valet parking and parking and all of that stuff.
I really much prefer public transportation. There was a while when I lived downtown that I took the subway in LA. I could take an Uber. This is in LA. Well, it went right downtown, so you take an Uber to the stop in Santa Monica and then take the train and then I could walk to my house.
Wow. That's a very LA way to take the subway. But anyway, the best thing. This van. And I'm in my second generation of van, but I always said if I made a hit movie, I was going to do this for myself. And the first hit I had was Paranormal Activity,
and I went right out. I bought myself a used Chevy Astro for $10,000. Now at that time, this is about 12 years ago, there were very few minivans with a flat bottom, like a handyman. All of the minivans had a hump for the back axle. I understand. So this was completely flat and so we took a minivan and I took it to a guy who did car stereos and gave him, I think, 20 grand? I think the whole thing was 30,000 bucks. And he built an office in the back,
so I had a computer, I had a keyboard, I had a printer. That's crazy. And the screen went up and down, all the windows closed, so I would make it impossible for myself to backseat drive, so I would never say, like, I would never think about, I wish you were going this route or this route or the traffic here or the traffic there. Because if you're in your thing and you're working,
it doesn't matter if it takes 20 minutes, if it takes 30 minutes. It's like a Waymo now. It's like a Waymo, exactly. So you're rolling calls, you're watching cuts, you're receiving faxes. I'm watching cuts, I'm doing my email, I'm printing out my boarding pass,
you could print out your little speech, I'm printing out my boarding pass. You could print out your little speech, I'm printing out my speech. And then if you need to park somewhere and there's no parking, what you did was you painted on the side of this van what? Oh, I did, I painted. It was an electrician van, but it said electric. Oh, commercial residential electrician, yeah. So it looked like an electrician. Blum power said electric, oh commercial residential electrician, yeah.
So it looked like an electrician. Blum power or something like that. Blum power, yeah exactly. It looked like a commercial vehicle. It looked like a commercial little handyman, it looked like a handyman. Yeah, one cone and you're good. You know who used to do that?
You know who used to do that a lot and was really effective for, was the Stasi, the secret police in this Germany, and they would drive around and it would look like a bread truck and they would nab people off the street and stuff them in the back and then take them to the Stasi headquarters, the torch room. You know what I mean? So this is...
The second part is a movie. We don't do that for real. Yeah, right. I actually bought speakers out of the back of some guy's van at a gas station. I did. That could have been the guy who redid my van. Did he have a flat bottom? And they were not real.
They were... No, otherwise it wouldn't have been interesting. And they weren't real, right? They were fake, they were empty, right? Yeah, they were empty, totally. Now Jason, you say your struggles with LA, that implies you came from somewhere, where is that place? Well, I was born in LA, I lived here till I was five,
and then I grew up in New York. I grew up until eighth grade, I went to public school in Dobbs Ferry in Westchester, grade. I went to public school in Dobbs Ferry in Westchester. And then I went to boarding school in Connecticut, which was very traumatic. And then I went to Vassar and Poughkeepsie. And then I lived in New York. For my first 10 years of motion picture shenanigans,
I lived in New York in the 90s. I graduated in 1991, so I was there from 91 to 2000. And then I moved to LA in 2000, and I've always thought about moving back, but I never really have. But when you first moved to LA, you alluded to the fact that you lived downtown. For a while, you lived in a hotel.
You never wanted to commit. I lived at the Ritz. Yeah, it was great. I love it. I still own the apartment, if anyone wants to buy. I cannot sell that thing for the life of me. What about the traffic about Laker games and stuff, though? Like when they were building crypto
or Staples or whatever. Oh, Laker games was amazing because I had great parking. I could just park at my house. Right. Well, I didn't really, I don't really go to the Lakers, but I could go to Staples to see shows. Yeah, but you couldn't get in and out. Yeah, I loved it.
It was great. It was rare. You know what you mean if he was going out with you. I know what you mean. Like if I was coming back and there was a Lakers game, yeah, sometimes it was a game in the ass. It wasn't that bad, it wasn't that bad. Now do you not miss, it just sounds so ideal,
first of all, I've seen the Vassar campus and it's incredibly beautiful. I can only imagine the boarding school in Connecticut was also gorgeous. When you moved out here to Los Angeles, did you not miss, because we're recording this in the wintertime here in LA, and it's just, the leaves are finally turning,
but it's like that most of the year in back east. Do you not miss all of that? Yes, I miss, that's what I'm saying. I struggle with living in LA, I miss it terribly. We're in Connecticut for the summer. I made a deal with my wife. My wife kind of prefers LA, but we made a deal that when school holidays we go to the East Coast.
So for all summer I get to be on the East Coast. But where you live in LA feels like the East Coast. Very wooded, foresty. That's true. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. You know what? Because you're a real estate agent, that's so funny by the way, I didn't know that. Huh? Wait, what?
He was a real estate agent. I was a licensed real estate agent. When? In New York. I did it for Chromon Real Estate, 1992, 1993, yeah, it was an amazing job. In New York City? In New York City. That was after I sold cable TV. First I sold cable TV door to door, commission only,
I made 29 bucks a sale, that's it, you only made money if you sold someone cable TV. For Time Warner? In Chicago, no, Prime Cable of Chicago. Yeah? Prime Cable of Chicago. I loved commission only jobs, and that's why, and the movies are the same thing.
I don't get paid on our movies. I only get paid if the movies work. And that started when I was really young, you know, doing shoveling driveways, and actually shoveling driveways is a good example of it, is if I had to work for a landscaper and you get like, you know, five bucks an hour, or you could go shovel driveways and say,
well, do your whole driveway, give me 10 bucks or 15 bucks. And I always, I hated getting paid always like a salary work for hire. I always liked getting paid for the exact work that I did. Right. Right. So when everyone else was a waiter, I sold cable because I'm like, I can make more money, if just pay me for the sales.
And the same thing with the real estate, when everyone else was a real estate agent, because you only got paid if you rented people apartments. And I always loved sales. That's cool, that's wild. I still love sales. Because you have the person, you have that, you're such an amazing personality
that I wondered if you, how did that kind of age you and when you crossed over to producing? Because you're such, you're so personable, everybody loves you. Yeah. Thank you in when you crossed over to producing because you're so personable, everybody loves you. Yeah. Thank you, thank you. The best, I always say that I think the best training I ever got for being a producer was real estate
because it's the same as being an actor, you get rejected all the time. So most people don't rent the apartment, right? Most movies you don't get, most movies you don't get made. So it got you very, it gets you very used to being rejected and you just got to keep trying. Very similar to acting, you got to keep trying and keep trying. And then it works, it's sales.
Every part of this business is sales unless you save a studio job and you're on the buying side. But even them, they're selling a direct, they're trying to, studio people are salespeople too. They're selling, they want directors directing they don't necessarily want to do. They want actors to do things they don't necessarily want to act in, right?
They want their boss to make a movie their boss doesn't necessarily want to make. Yeah, every song. Everyone's selling, everyone's selling to a certain degree. And your company's so big now you're doing both sales and you're buying and selling at the same time, right? Yeah we do buy in all the time trying to sort of sell you a pitch on something and you've got to make a decision and Do you like toggling back and forth between that? I do I do I like toggling back and forth buying
I would you get a bumper sticker that says I like to toggle I'd rather be toggling. I'd rather be toggling. I'd actually paint that on my van. I like to be toggled. I'm like Jason, I like to do both sides. I like to do both sides. Toggling electric. Toggling electric.
Toggling electric. Toggling electric. The long lost switch. Let me ask you this. Okay, I want to get into this. What is the current, you and I have talked about this before. I said, well, can we do a comedy,
I remember about a year and a half ago or something we had lunch and I said, can we do, make a comedy? You said, there's no money in it. And I said, really? I mean, in effect you said that. The state of movies. There's no money for me in it.
There's no money for you in it. Right, yeah. No, no, I got it, don't worry. You're not getting paid. You're not getting paid until noon. I got it. I'm not getting, I'm not the comedian. Yeah, no, no, I got it. Don't worry. You're not getting paid until New York. I got it. I'm not getting paid, I'm not the comedian. Yeah, no, no, I got it, I read that.
But what is the state of theatrical films on this planet right now from your perspective? Can people still make them? Can they make money? Do people want to go and see them? Okay, let's just clear the record. On the comedy, my response was not, I can't make money in it, although that is true,
but the reason that we don't do comedy is because you, I don't, I think horror really works, you don't need massive, massive stars for theatrical horror. Yeah, because it's about the idea. TV, different thing, TV comedy, different thing, but for comedy, for a horror. TV, different thing. TV comedy, different thing. But for comedy, for a comedy to work,
comedy is just very hard to work in movie theaters. There's so much great comedy. All of you guys have been part of a lot of it on television. Horror doesn't really work on TV. There's a lot of great comedy on TV. So to make, and for comedy to work theatrically, I still think it's very hard anyway, and you need a huge star
so that it becomes expensive. And there was a time as you know. I don't like making expensive movies. As we know, there was a time, especially in the early aughts where there were a ton of big comedy films driven by big stars. But as we know, especially if we go back and look at a lot of them, I've always maintained
it's hard to make a good comedy film because of the nature of making film does not lend itself to that element of surprise, et cetera. In television, you have to make it quickly, you have to keep moving, and so it works for comedy in that way. Making movies, it can be often tedious and quite boring, A, that's one.
But, so it's funny that comedy works on TV and horror does not and vice versa. But what about the state of theatrical movies, of film? Well, this is constantly on my mind. And I actually texted, I texted Aaron this morning, who runs all the AMC theaters, because they had their biggest weekend ever. Right.
And I keep trying, I've been asking everyone, I trust on that, like, is this like an anomaly, or do you think? Yeah, but look at what worked. It's Wicked, which was an IP already established for 20 years. There's Gladiator 2, which was a massive movie. Moana, which was an institution in and of itself.
Two sequels. Well, that's different. If you're saying, people don't want original movies. They don't. Like, they say that they want them, but actions speak louder than words. That's right. People want the reason they're all sequels and remakes,
that that's what they want. That's what the audience is showing up to that consistently, consistently, consistently, and even more so now, if you look at horror this year, one horror movie in 12 months really hit. Original. There were six or seven sequels that worked, but one original horror.
I don't think you'd have to go long legs. I want to see that. I think you'd have to go long legs. Long legs. I want to see that. I think you'd have to go back ten years for... For... To see where only one original horror movie worked. I mean, it's... Have there been any outliers in terms of films that... Horror and or otherwise that have done well in the last, let's say,
since the pandemic, since 2020, in the last four and a half years? Anything? Well, yeah, our high Five Nights at Freddy's was last year, it was our highest grossing movie of all time. Wow. And that was the original?
No, it's based on a game. Based on an IP, yeah. But based on a game. Based on a game, yeah, yeah, yeah. But that did 300 million bucks. I'm trying to think. We had our best, Megan was one, Megan was a huge movie, Black Phone was a huge movie,
Quiet Place is not our movie, huge movie, Conjuring. Those were post, Quiet Place was this year, those were all post-pandemic. Horror franchises are, like I said, we had our Insidious Five last year, it was the highest grossing Insidious movie of all five of them. And that was last year.
And it was the most insidious most I'm sure you've seen all five of the fire So hey so Jason without getting too much into the weeds for for folks like Tracy Can you speak what do you think the current appetite is in the business for these sort of these trick deals where instead of an actor getting paid a bunch of money up front, like when you're talking about this scenario with comedy
where by having a big star in there, it becomes sort of cost prohibitive. But I think some actors, Cameron Diaz is one of the famous ones that did it for a teacher. Bad teacher. A bad teacher where she basically didn't take a lot of money up front, but then had this definition
for the back end of a profit participant where if the film did really well, she got paid a lot of money and she did. Because I know your model, without getting into stuff you may or may not want to talk about, you seem to be open to this type of structure in the interest of trying to get as many at-bats as possible in the hopes of finding a great movie.
Well, no, it's more than that. That's our main tenant of our entire business is no one gets paid up front, including us. Just like my real estate and just like my cable TV, no one gets paid, or you get paid minimum scale, and if the movie works okay, you get paid minimum scale and if the movie works okay, you get paid okay and if the movie works really well, you should get paid more than you've ever made before.
That's our whole, I wrote. What about your toggle business? The toggle business is also an if come business by the way. It's a fantastic if come business. Yes. But I remember you saying that, I remember you Blum talking about, and who I won't name, but an actor
who was in one of your films in the last five, 10 years, who's a well-known actor, who you said, they made more money doing this. They took nothing up front. They made more money doing this than they'd made on anything else. They'd ever done. Yeah, that's true.
That's true. And that's how we keep getting people to work for us and take a gamble. And you didn't mind doing that, right? You didn't mind writing those checks to that actor. The greatest thing I can ever do is if I write the biggest check to anyone's ever made on my... That means a gun law.
It's like complaining about paying a lot of taxes. Like if you're paying a lot of taxes, things are going well. Amen. Yeah, so then why do you think that's not more universally embraced? Well, so I wrote an article in the New York Times. It was an op-ed. I was very proud of it, and you can go back and read it.
Oh, I don't read. Tracy, no, Tracy can go back and read it. Tracy can read it to me. Or I'll read it to you, yeah. For New York Times. And it was all about the fact that I believe, if there's one, there are no rules to making movies and TV shows in my mind except one, which is if people have equity in what they're making
as opposed to being paid upfront, what they're making is better. It just is. Absolutely, I totally agree. And that view has been very not, has been very out of fashion until the streaming correction, which happened about 18 months ago. But to put it in very broad terms,
starting in about 2010, there was an enormous amount of money. Wall Street gave not just Netflix, but all the streamers money, not based on their profit, but based on subscriber numbers. And the way to get subscriber numbers was to spend more and more and more and more. And so the industry as a whole spent more money than it was making because it wasn't using profit as a metric. Right. You with me? Yeah. 18 months ago when Netflix stock dropped,
it's now back to beyond what it was before, which is going to tie into what I'm saying. But 18 months ago, when Netflix stock dropped, it's now back to beyond what it was before, but 18 months ago, Wall Street decided, that's dumb, streaming companies and media companies need to be like every other company, numbers or anything else or what you might eventually make in streaming, we're going to reward you for what actually makes money so that all the people who make content had to take a much closer look at their budgets. And the budgets are now all coming down a lot. And the quickest, most effective way to bring a budget down is to pay the people who make
the most money, which are the actors, the writers, the directors, and the producers, people who make the most money, much less unless the thing that they make makes money. And that's now... But the trick with streaming is that the ability to calculate what a profit is becomes vague, yes? Yes, but it's not it. That's such gobbledygook. It's the easiest thing in the world to create.
They have the data of everything, you just have to decide. A penny a minute, a penny an hour, it doesn't, it's so. Whatever everybody universally decides on. It's way easier to make up a profit definition, yes. Here's the other thing that's interesting about it. I got carried away, go ahead. No, no, no, I think this is a great area,
this is the other thing, cause it's, and I think that, I think that it's pretty cynical in the sense that the streamers, like you said, were given exorbitant amounts of cash to try to do that, to grow their business and to get subs. Well, it turns out that they figured out within that time, and this is probably five years ago, they realized when they started to offer things,
they started to offer ad customers, ad-supported customers, they realized that their ad-supported customer was worth more to them than a subscriber, that they would get more return on it. And so eventually, what the consumer doesn't understand that eventually we are gonna be going back to the old formula from before. Network television.
Yeah, so we're just coming to the tail end of this huge fucking cycle that was virtually meaningless. And now we're back to ad supported viewing is gonna be the thing that they are going after, et cetera. Am I right? Streaming is just basically an electrified VCR. That's all it is.
You can watch anything whenever you want, but otherwise it's going to be like it was before. I don't know if I totally agree with that, but it's changed a lot and it's changed not very much. I do agree with most of what you're saying. Yeah, because all the people that work at the streamers worked at the networks. Well, that's true.
They're almost all the same people. That's true. That culture has shifted and all that stuff that they said that separated them and made them different at all the streamers now does not separate them or make them different and it's very, very difficult. Well, but hang on.
I mean, we're talking about something that for the most part is subscriber supported. The ad supported viewer is a small fraction of that. And they want it to be bigger. Not as a part of the general population because people still watch a lot of network TV, but for streaming, ad supportedsupported streaming is a smaller piece than subscription for streaming.
Yeah, and it's still hard to argue with, you know, having 250 million people spending $15 a month is a pretty yummy business if you can retain those people month after month after month after month, and it really is, it's a retention business. It's not an ad selling business. Did you know? Well, it'll be both.
You'll have, and by the way, movies are different in a different category than what you guys are talking about, studios, it's different, but there will be a bunch of people, a bunch of subscribers paying a premium for no ads, and then there'll be a bunch of people watching programming with ads for either less or no money. JB, I don't disagree with you.
What I'm saying is that that is what they have decided that they want to move towards because it is more profitable. And I guarantee you, all of them are going to tend towards the thing that is more profitable. It's what they want. If it was more profitable, then why wouldn't linear television be in better health? Well, there are, because there are things
that are showing up to be, that are proving that, which are things like 2B and all these sort of fast channel type things. These are proving to be really effective ways that people are watching stuff who don't wanna have to pay the subscriber a monthly fee and who are willing to watch ads. And that kind of stuff, that stuff is growing.
It's all about what's available. Wait, what is Tubi? Do I have Tubi? That's a long callback. That is a, that's like a three year callback. Jason Blum, I want to talk about your stuff, because I'm a fan. And so first of all, I wanted to-
Okay, well then start. You're a guest today. So paranormal- He's got 17 million questions for you. I do, I do. Paranormal Activity is one of my favorite movies. I watched it a year ago with my nieces. Yep, quote it.
Well, just, I could talk about it all day long. Then start. Okay. Keep saying it. You're like a rapper could talk about it all day long. Then start. Okay. Keep saying, you're like a rapper who goes, I'm going to rock the microphone, wait till I get on the mic. And you're like, okay, you've got the microphone. Fucking do it. The fuck? I'm going to rock the mic.
And when I get on the microphone, I'm really going to, then fucking do it. That's how I felt about this mystery product coming in. Yeah, I know that's true. That's true, fair enough, fair enough. Oh, I'm, oh, by the way, I'm a hypocrite in my core. Well, but Jason, tell me about it, because wasn't it true that the studio wanted you to remake it, or they didn't like it,
or whatever, and how did you convince them that they had gold and all that kind of stuff? Tell me about this one. Paranormal Activity, I'll do the quicker version of it. Yeah, yeah, yeah, that was what launched the company. But I had a guy, this very sweet fellow who I'm still friends with and a very good producer, a guy named Steven Schneider, and he was a horror expert.
I had a deal at Paramount and he had a deal with us and we had a deal with them. And Paramount, you know, whatever, was ignoring me. And this guy, Steven, showed me this movie, showed me Paranormal Activity and I saw it like, you know, on a DVD at my house. And it'd been at a couple festivals and whatever. And...
You were living in New York at the time? I was, no, I was living on Sunset Plaza, in my bachelor pad on Sunset Plaza, before I moved downtown. And... And... Exactly. And...
And I had passed on Blair Witch Project, like... I can't believe that. And now you're remaking it. Yes. We're trying. We're trying. We'll see. Yeah, we're trying.
I know. Crazy. No. But yeah, I passed on it, and I was never like, my boss just was like, you idiot for a year, you know? A year, I had to listen to that. But when I saw Paranormal, I had this like, oh my God, what if this is Blair Witch? And I didn't say like, this movie's gonna be,
I didn't think the movie's gonna be anything of what it turned out to be, but I definitely thought there was something to it, and I thought it was worth screening it in front of an audience. That's what I learned from Blair Witch, is if you see anything somewhat that might be good, throw it in front of an audience.
Yes, because we love testing. I love testing. So anyway. The smile on his face when you said that. No, but it's true, I've heard you talk about that. Testing is my dream, yeah. I don't like friends and family testing. I like testing with real, objective people.
Testing the film in front of a random audience. Regular audience. And then they all fill out what they like, what they didn't like, and you get a number. I'm not such a big fan of that, but I like watching the movie with a regular crowd. Got it. Yeah, it's the best feedback ever, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So anyway, I have this itch I want to scratch on this movie and I met the director and he had basically sold it to a, he sold it for 100 grand to direct a DVD, to IFC, by the way, who never forget, a guy named Jonathan Searing was there at the time, he never forgave me for this. Because I said, it's a deal done,
he said, no, it's not done, but I think I'm going to just sell it for 100. Because I said, it's a deal done. He said, no, it's not done, but I think I'm going to just sell it for 100 grand. I said, I think the movie should be in theaters. I told him the Blair Witch story. I said, give me a cut of whatever you make after you make $500,000. So I'm not going to cost you anything unless I make five times the money you've already made.
Then I want a piece, but until then, nothing. And let me come on and partner, see if I can get it made with you. Anyway, three years goes by, no one wants the movie. I do the movie with the audience like I want to do. It's very clear if you see the movie with an audience, it's going to be a crazy hit, it's very clear. But I'm the, you know, schmuck producer.
I call everyone and say, you got to watch this movie with an audience. They say, well, we've already seen it. We have got the DVD here. It's sitting on my assistant's desk and the movie sucks. And, and... That's so good. That's the way a lot of conversations go in Hollywood. Yeah, exactly.
Wow. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. So three years into this, I get Paramount won't return my calls and it still drives me crazy that the movie wound up with them because they hated the movie forever. But I get DreamWorks, this guy Adam Goodman. I know Adam.
You know Adam, you remember Adam, right? Yeah, of course, great guy, made a couple movies with him. Yeah, Adam and Ashley Brooks, and they're working at DreamWorks, and they're really into the movie, I give them credit for that, and they said, well, we're going to remake the movie, you know, we'll put famous people in the movie.
Movies have found footage movies, so I don't know how it could work with famous people, but I say, this is my flash of brilliance, of which I've had two in my career, but this was one of them. And I said, I will, first of all, you gotta pay me 150 grand, because I need more than 100 for Oran,
so I gotta get him an extra 50 grand. Second, you gotta put the original movie on the DVD. When we remake the new movie, you gotta put the original movie on that DVD, because I want it out there somewhere. Oh, wow. Third, you have to test the original parent-owned activity. You have to test screen the film in Burbank
with 300 people and you, Adam, and it was Stacey Snyder, his boss, and Stacey Snyder, you guys have to be there. And not because I want to release the movie because if I said that, they would have said, you're an idiot. I said because when we remake the movie, I want to release the movie, because if I said that, they would have said, you're an idiot. I said, because when we remake the movie, I want to invite the writers
who are going to write the remake, and I want all you executives to be there with the writers so we can decide which parts we're going to redo and which parts we're going to leave, right? I love that, I love that. And then I said to the director, Oren, who I give Oren so much credit for sticking with me all this time,
three years into this, he had 150 grand three years ago, he's still, he's sleeping in my guest house for half the time, he was in San Diego, but he used to sleep in my guest house all the time for all these dumb meetings we would have where people would say the movies doesn't work. And I said to Oren, Oren, I will bet you a nickel that if Adam and Stacey
watch this movie with a recruited audience, which was impossible to do, if they watch this movie with a recruited audience, they're never going to talk about the remake again. Just trust me. And by the way, worst case scenario, if they do, you're going to get a buck 50 instead of a hundred, so it's no loose.
And I still remember, Warren, Steven, and I went to this screening, it was in Burbank, and Stacey was there, and fucking people went insane. And three people left the theater because they were too scared. And the movie ends and everyone goes nuts, and Stacey, I will never forget, Stacey Snyder is at the bottom of the,
and she's literally, the writers were there for the remake, they disappear, and Stacey has the three of us pitching us the 30 second TV spots of how she's going to sell the movie. The theatrical release. Wow. The movie as is. As is. The remake's off the table, and then Spielberg gets
the results of the test, he sees it like two days later. He loves it. And DreamWorks is releasing our movie. And then, and another thing, I won't go into it now, but DreamWorks then and Paramount split up. And DreamWorks went to Disney. And Disney, DreamWorks could not have their first release be Paranormal Activity.
So we were saddled with Paramount and another year of shenanigans, which is how it wound up with them. No way, another year from that moment? It was a year, they said they weren't going to release it. They blackmailed us, they blackmailed us into releasing them, I've never really been this straightforward about it, but I will be now.
We had, based off that test screening, we were able to sell five million bucks of international sales. So based off the fact that it was gonna get a domestic release by a studio, we had five million dollars in sales. All the France and Germany, we sold territory by territory, right?
You're already in profit. We had, oh my God, in profit, but the movie cost 15 grand. So we had 18 months to get the release, which by the way, no problem. Stacey and Steven Spielberg loved the movie. Dreamworks is releasing the movie, boom. Disney were at Paramount. Paramount's like, we're not releasing the movie.
Wow. And it went on and they- Why were they opposed to releasing it? They thought it was a piece of shit, like everybody else. Wow. But what about this? The only savior was that when Disney and DreamWorks broke up, Adam Goodman and Ashley Brooks moved-
Went to Paramount. From DreamWorks to Paramount. So internally, they were doing what I was doing on the outside. So on the outside, I was... And internally, they were saying, guys, you got to... But everyone was saying to them, you guys are insane, don't do this movie. And basically, what happened, in retrospect,
history is rewritten like they did this strategic smart release. No. Adam and Ashley got them to agree to pay a million bucks in P&A to do this tiny release of the movie. Print and advertise. a strategic smart release. and we'll put 500 up and we'll put it in 13 theaters. Demand it, which was only, that was, the whole marketing thing was just like, how can we spend as little money as possible to get this movie out there? I mean, isn't it amazing you have that? Wow! That's actually,
I've never really, really told that part of the story, but it's a great thing. It's amazing. But isn't it amazing that you have this thing and what it takes to get people to believe in it and you just didn't stop, and isn't it fascinating that you have this thing and what it takes to get people to believe in it and you just didn't stop. And isn't it fascinating that you can see it, but the people in charge can never see it? Why is that?
Well, no, it's, you know, those stories though, I mean, you guys know these stories too. It's, I have a little, like, it's always annoying, the story, there's so many stories of I believed in it and nobody didn't. Right, sure. And it's, it favors the producer so much, because executives, their job is to look at 400 things
and pick 10. So they have to not believe in 390 things. So it's not really fair. Producer's job is to pick 20 things, believe in all of them, and 10 go, you know, whatever it is. So I always think those stories are kind of dopey, including this story. Like, I don't...
It's fascinating though. It's... No, I don't, it's fascinating except it's not like, I give myself credit for that one thing of, of, you know, putting that language in the test screening, but anyone, any of you or anyone, if you saw the movie with an audience before it came out, you would know it was a hit.
It's just I couldn't get anyone into the theater. Right, right, right. There was no genius of knowing that. But you did, and it still took all of that work to get it a wide release. Well, I had no clout. I had no clout. It's like this little, this guy with? Well, I had no clout. I had no clout. You know, it's like this little, you know, this
guy with no, like I had no track record. I produced six independent movies. They were all terrible. One was okay and five were horrible. So it was like, why am I going to, why am I going to waste my night and be away from my kids by this schmuck, when everyone in my team has seen the movie and they think it's not good, which by the way, which I get too. How under the hood do you like to get creatively as far as script notes and edit notes and all that? I hate being on set.
I like running my production company. I give usually a couple of notes on a script, a few notes on a cut, depending on the cut. Sometimes I give more notes on the finished movie than the script, but Cooper Samuelson, who you know well, he's the, he's the, The great Cooper Samuelson. He's the great, we've been together 10 years,
and he really runs the movie, no, he does run the movie company, and he is very, he and his team are extremely involved. What would you say is your fastball then? Like identifying a filmmaker, a concept, a script, where do you think your greatest talent lies if it's not getting in there under the hood day to day, quality control, et cetera, et cetera?
Well, I'm a great picker, I'm a good picker. I'm a very good picker, I am a good picker. So that is quality control. And I'm a good seller. And I'm not talking about, it's easy to raise money for the movies now, but I'm good at talking people into working for me, working for us. I'm good at it.
But it's an easy thing for me, it's an easy thing to sell because I believe it. I really believe in our model and I believe in the company and I believe the model leads to better movies and shows. The only thing that I was going to say is there's really no other companies that just do one thing. And that's been a huge advantage to us. And now, the second, the only other company that really does just do one thing like we do at scale is James Wan's Atomic Monster.
And now Atomic Monster and Blumhouse, we put the companies together 16 months ago. And it's a huge advantage to not do horror as like a side hustle. You know, which that's what the studios do obviously, but also most production company, most other production companies, they do all the thing and we do the occasional horror movie. And that's all we do.
I see every horror movie. That's- Well, Blum, that's, of course you're occasional horror movie and that's all we do. I see every horror movie That's of course you're good at because that is what you do your specialty you understand it Now you have you're doing it with James Wan talk a little bit about your your relationship with James Wan and and how that came to be well I'm interested in growing the company and I really felt like this kind of this is actually kind of It kind of ties together a lot of the stuff that we've been talking about.
It's that I don't believe you can make, let's just talk about movies and not TV for a second. I don't believe you can make movies, you can make more movies that are good by just hiring more people, right? And remember, we only get paid if our movies are good or if they work. If they don't work, we don't get paid.
So for us to go from four or five movies a year to seven or eight movies a year, we have to keep the quality the same. If the quality goes down, it's a disaster. So the only way for us to grow is to go from four or five to six or seven. And it was my view that the only way to get to six or seven. And it was my view that the only way to get to six or seven was to bring in a partner,
not just to hire four more executives, but to bring in a partner who was a visionary who was doing this on his own. And if you take Blumhouse and Atomic Monster and if those two companies just continue to do what the an atomic monster and if those two companies just continue to do what the companies have done on their own the last 10 years, it's like 60% of theatrically released horror movies have been done by those two companies. Yeah, talking about James Wan, some of the things that he's done.
So James Wan, first of all, he's a massive director, separate business, Aquaman, Fast and Furious, right, but he birthed Insidious with us, which is how I met him. But Atomic Monster is best known as the production company behind The Conjuring Universe. So all the Conjuring movies, Annabelle, La Llorona. Huge. Huge.
It's a, yeah, The Nun, The Nun 2. Nun 2, no one ever talks about it, but Nun 2 was the second highest grossing horror movie of all time last year. No one? Wow! $270 million, the Nun 2. No one talks about it in Hollywood. So anyway, so next year, 25 is our first year
where our release date slate will be, we're up to our eight movies. We have Wolfman, we have two original movies, we have a Chris Landon movie called Drop, and then we have Megan, then we have Black Phone, then we have Five Nights at Freddy's 2, and then these guys have a Mortal Kombat movie and a Conjuring 5 movie.
So next year is our big year. What percentage of box office does horror make up now, domestically? It's like a billion dollars a year. Billion dollars a year. Which is what percentage? It's about eight, nine, right about 10%. Good Lord.
So every award show where we're lauding all these other people, they should do, the first five minutes should just be a standing O for you and Juan, just to say thank you for keeping us all at work and now let's get to the Oscars. Five minutes standing O, Blum. Right, and they are, starting a long time ago, they've got really cinematic and less sort of like, you know, the rap they used to get with Slasher and Exploitative and whatnot. They're like beautifully made films now.
Yeah, there's less TNA, I will say that. I'm sorry, not to knock it. Sorry about that. Now, do you know, I heard, maybe someone has talked to you about this on the show, but do you know, I heard that kids don't want TNA in movies now because there's so much of it on the internet that they don't want TNA in movies anymore.
Wow, no kidding. Makes sense. Yeah, real progress. Yeah, and they don't want TNA in movies anymore. Wow, no kidding. I'm not kidding. Yeah, real progress. Yeah, and they don't want their driver's license either because there's Uber, you know. If you can get it somewhere else, I don't want it here. Jason Blum, I'm a big fan of Get Out and we don't have time to go through it
because we're going to let you go, but I didn't know there was. Oh my God, you're already over time. Jason, you're very, I didn't even know. This might be the quickest we've ever gotten to it and feel like we're just starting. Yeah, we really are. I got so much more to go into. God, I thought you were going to be a disappointing guest. I know, but in four years.
Bateman kept saying, I'm not going to respond to this guy's emails. Don't respond to him. Can't make a deal. No, I can imagine before the show, I said, did Blum email you the other week? Oh my goodness, this guy won't stop. Who's going to break first, then Sean? Oh my gosh, Sean broke first. Wait, Sean had a question though, do ask it.
Call her? No, well, it's too long to get into and I can probably just Google it, but I did not know there was a different ending to Get Out. There was, that was a note I had, that was a note I had. There was an end date to get out where Daniel died. And, or Daniel wound up in jail. Wound up in jail.
Something terrible. Did they write it? Did they shoot it? Yeah, we shot it. It was at the test screening. And we tested it. And me and my very like, you know, not thoughtful self, I come bounding down the aisle
and I'm like, Jordan, the movie's great. You cannot leave this end. I'm like, I didn't hedge, I didn't want to, you have to change the end. I said, Daniel is too good, everyone is in love with him, the movie's amazing, and you cannot end him with him in jail, like, it's just, it's horrible. And did Jordan say, yeah, but that was your idea?
Yeah, he said, yeah, he said, but that was your note. No, he was amazing. You sent me that note from the back of your van. You said you were on Cahuenga. You idiot, you idiot. No, he was a man. No, I pitched him some horrible idea of what it should be to keep him alive.
So in the originals, she, I forget the name of the character, the girl in it, the lead girl. Alison Williams. Alison Williams. She, I haven't seen her in a long time, but she ends up getting him in jail, is that what it is? I think, now I'm forgetting, but I think the end, he's in jail, he winds up in jail.
Like there's a scene of him like in jail. Wow, yeah, it's so good how it is. It's like so sad. And Jordan, you know, a month later, he had a new idea for the end, he reshot it. What a filmmaker he is. Amazing filmmaker. Amazing filmmaker.
Amazing. Tell me your favorite horror film. Oh, just a softball right here at the end. and he reshot it and it's like an amazing film maker. Tell me your favorite horror film. Oh, just a softball right here at the end. Yeah, just so we can alienate everybody he works with, other than the person he names. Any funny stories of you going up on a line on stage? I like Hitchcock movies, those are my favorite, in terms of like, those are my inspiration movies.
Yeah. Okay, so listen, you gotta get outta here. We gotta get outta here. What Blumhouse movies are we gonna go to, are people gonna come and see in 2025? Tell us right now. He just did. Well, I did.
Wolfman is January, it's great. It's Lee Wanell who did The Invisible Man. It's amazing. Is that Julia Garner? Julia Garner and Chris Abbott. Yeah, and it's great. So Wolfman is-El who did The Invisible Man. It's amazing. Is that Julia Garner? Julia Garner and Chris Abbott. Yeah, and it's great. Okay, so Wolfman is January, okay. Wolfman is January.
This original movie by Chris Landon who did Happy Death Day. Michael Landon's son. Michael Landon's son called Drop with Megan Fahey, which is great. Drop. And then we have Megan II. Megan II. At the summer release.
Summer release. Then we have Black Phone Two. Black Phone Two. That's Scott Derrickson with the Great Ethan Hawke. Back is the grabber. Back is the grabber. I thought they caught him. Then we have Five Nights at Freddy's Two.
Now clearly you guys missed the first one. Ten Nights at Freddy's. You've got 12 months to see the first and then see the second. Ten Nights at Freddy's. Christmas release. 12 months to see the first and then see the second. 10 Nights at Freddy's. Christmas release? Christmas release. If you're doing the math. December release and our friends at Atomic Monster
have the next Conjuring movie, have Mortal Kombat. So it's a big year. It's a full slate of great movies. It's a monster year. You should consider doing the year after for Five Nights at Freddy's, do it as a great movie. It's a monster year. You should consider doing the year after for Five Nights at Freddy's. Do it as a Christmas movie, 12 Nights at Freddy's, tied into Christmas.
Yeah, it's a great idea. That's a freebie. You're welcome, it's a free one. It's a free one from us to you. Blumhouse is bringing you all the movies you want to see. Go and see them. We urge you, we urge you to go and see them. And you are an unbelievable guest.
Well, you're an unbelievable guy. It took me four years,, it was a lot of fun. You're an unbelievable guy. It took me four years, but there was a lot of pressure. I had to make it worth it. Fuck, you delivered. Thank you, guys. You delivered. Thank you for having me. Jason, you're the best.
I appreciate it. Say hi to Lauren, please. Okay, I will. Lots of love to all of you. Love you, and congrats, by the way, your new daughter. Thank you, thank you, my little daughter. Bye, buddy. All right, thanks, guys.
Bye, pal. The man is a gift for Gab. You know, we could expand this to four hosts, very easily come in here. But aside from, totally, aside from buying a movie from him, I would buy a house from him. I know. Yeah. I'd let him shovel my driveway.
Yeah. I'd let him shovel my driveway. I'd let him fix my wiring. I don't deal with the electric van. No, a very, very good person. And so is his wife. And it's just, I don't know. A good guy.
And a perfect example of how to succeed. You know, like when you're kind of starting out in this business, if there's any young producers out there, it's a perfect person to kind of, you know, look for inspiration of how he did it. I know, but it's like, how would you say, like, you know, he does have, I was trying to break down, like what's the recipe to become Jason Blunt?
His personality. I mean, but not to belittle his ability in the business, but people skills is an enormous part of this industry no matter what lane you're in. That's true, and I will say this, and I will say he has the, I was thinking about it too throughout the thing, like what is it that makes him so successful,
other than he says that he's a good picker, he's got tremendous people skills, he understands, but he's really smart. Yeah, you have to be a lot of things. But he's really smart. Yeah. You have to be a lot of things and he's a lot of things. So like it's a good place to start is being really smart. Yeah. You know, JB, nothing?
Huh? Oh, no, I was looking at a text and I thought, are we getting in? Now we know why you're not him. And attentive. Now we know why you're not him. Cause he would never do that. No, no, not at all.
Well, Rob Armier, stop fucking texting me while we're doing the wrap up. God damn it. Rob was texting you? We have pickups, we have pickups we have to get to. So let's get to a buy, Sean, you have anything on the list? I don't have anything on the list that fits. Really?
How about, you know, let's try a new thing. I'm gonna give you a word here that I'd like for you to work into a buy, okay? And the word is buy for Kate. Okay, Will, would you like to go first? We did that one last week, right? Okay, how about? How about a buyback?
What's a buyback? A buyback. What is a buyback? Somebody with two backs? A buyback would be if you wanted to purchase something back from somebody. Oh, I would never want to do that to one of his films. I would never want to go into his film after seeing something so spectacular and ask for a...
You would never need to. I would never need to go into his face. I feel like this is going to be really lazy. I would never ask for or need a buyback. I feel like this is gonna be really lazy. I feel like this is really lazy. I would never ask for a knee day. Bye back. Bye. We all even saw it coming. Instead of get out, it could be called bye.
What's that Michael? Instead of get out, it could be called bye. Bye. There you go. Oh yes. it didn't clear It was already taken what you have the original title for get out was by Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarve, and Bennett Barbico.
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.